hombres que exhiben fusiles de asalto en
la calle
que tienen vehículos en las carreteras
de manera arbitraria
y desafían abiertamente a las
autoridades
estamos en Haití donde más de 150 bandas
imponen su ley la mayoría de estos
grupos armados están en Puerto Príncipe
la capital controlan gran parte de la
ciudad incluyendo las principales vías a
finales de octubre bloqueaban el acceso
a la mayor terminal petrolera y al
Principal Palacio de Justicia del país
masacres Balas Perdidas secuestros las
primeras víctimas son los habitantes
Mira todas esas casas están vacías hay
casi nadie Algunos murieron otros fueron
quemados vivos las bandas han estado
activas en Haití desde hace años pero
según nuestros observadores Ahora son
todopoderosas
no le temen a la policía no le temen a
nadie no le temen a la ley
esta inseguridad se suma a un contexto
económico y político tenso
agravado por el asesinato del presidente
renal muiss en julio de 2021 desde
entonces el país ha estado dirigido por
el Primer Ministro águilalong cuya
legitimidad es cuestionada cómo explicar
el poder de estas bandas Y cómo las
enfrentan las autoridades haitianas
a través de videos de aficionados y de
testimonios que suelen ser anónimos por
razones de seguridad investigamos sobre
las violencias de las bandas en Puerto
Príncipe
[Música]
enojo
en un barrio
tenía 28 años
24 fueron asesinadas el 20 de agosto
junto con su madre josef
el asesinato de las tres mujeres se
produjo A las afueras de Puerto Príncipe
mientras se dirigían a la universidad
en el camino Fueron atacadas por la
banda de los 400 Magos
[Música]
no existen imágenes del ataque pero este
vídeo firmado cuando llegó la policía
muestra el vehículo de la familia de
Sound en llamas
ese día Johnson Club perdió a su mujer y
a sus dos hijas
al llegar al lugar la calle Estaba
totalmente desierto
solo se podía ver la carcasa del aula
no encontré a nadie Fui a una funeraria
para identificar los cuerpos
los bandidos quisieron secuestrarlas
ella se resistieron y en ese momento los
maleantes dispararon sobre las damas
mi vida mi vida entera
este drama conmocionó a los haitianos e
hizo reaccionar al Primer Ministro
estoy indignado por la noticia del
asesinato de varios compatriotas por
bandos armados reitero mi firme
determinación para combatir sin descanso
la inseguridad
las reacciones en los altos niveles del
Estado son escasas en Haití las
autoridades son acusadas de permanecer
pasivas incluso cuando las bandas
cometen masacres a gran escala del 24 de
abril al 6 de mayo en la zona de
planyucuil la banda de los 400 mauso
atacó a la de Show me show
ahora sí estamos en su territorio
tenemos el control
al menos 191 personas murieron las tres
cuartas partes eran simples habitantes
los sobrevivientes decidieron huir
decidimos irnos un martes porque el
lunes en la noche los tiros no pararon
ni un minuto
la policía llegó a la zona justo después
de que nos fuéramos
en el barrio de cite su ley del 7 al 17
de julio hubo otros enfrentamientos se
oponían dos importantes coaliciones de
bandas el g9 onfanía alie dirigido por
un antiguo policía llamado barbecue y el
gepet dirigido por un hombre que se hace
llamar cigarriel
hubo más de 300 muertos allí los
habitantes volvieron a huir de las
violencias pero también de la escasez en
el barrio bloqueado por los
enfrentamientos
ahora dónde se van Estamos buscando agua
y comida porque nuestros hijos están
llorando según la red Nacional de
defensa de los Derechos Humanos una
organización haitiana que ha documentado
ambas masacres la policía ha adoptado
una postura no intervencionista
el mutismo de las autoridades estatales
demuestra para nosotros en la red
Nacional de defensa de los Derechos
Humanos que hay pandas armadas que gozan
de la protección
de la bendición de las autoridades
estatales y además de eso tenemos la
impresión de que para ellos la población
civil debe arreglárselas aunque esté
atrapada entre esas bandas armadas que
están en guerra
[Música]
esta adolescente fue alcanzada por una
bala perdida el video lo grabó nuestro
observador uno de sus vecinos en solinó
en este Barrio Las Bandas no se
enfrentan directamente pero los
habitantes suelen ser Víctimas de las
Balas Perdidas
Hay personas que se esconden debajo de
su cama para protegerse de las balas Que
atraviesen el techo de sus casas
la mayoría de los techos son de chapa
entonces realmente no resisten contra
las balas
a veces hay heridos e incluso muertos
un amigo mío mientras estaba acostado en
su cama sintió algo caliente que le cayó
la pierna
Yo quiero un proyectil y mirando de
dónde venía se dio cuenta de que había
un hueco en el techo de su habitación
Buenos días después estábamos juntos
hablando bromeando en la calle
oímos un ruido y mirando el suelo
encontramos otro proyectil
le mostramos esta bala a un experto en
balística Y ésta ambas pueden matar a
más de un kilómetro de distancia y están
destinadas a armas de guerra en redes
sociales las bandas exhiben esas armas
con orgullo
Este es por ejemplo un fusil m16 a2
este un fusil tipo ak-47 con sus armas
las bandas están mejor equipadas que la
policía
los policías mueren de manera general
cuando hay enfrentamientos entre las
bandas armadas y la policía
y también lo segundo es que es una
policía que muchas veces está obligado a
batirse en retirada
la policía está mal equipada a causa de
las restricciones impuestas por Estados
Unidos sobre la venta de armas al Estado
haitiano un problema al que se suman su
falta de efectivos y los vínculos entre
algunos policías y las bandas
por su parte las bandas adquieren armas
y municiones que entran ilegalmente a
Haití la mayoría provenientes de Estados
Unidos
para comprar esas armas cuentan con el
dinero que ganan a través de los
rescates que piden por los secuestros
[Música]
en este vídeo el jefe de la Banda
sankswagen provoca a las autoridades
después de haber secuestrado a 38
personas
imágenes
[Música]
uno de nuestros observadores al que
llamaremos Patrick fue víctima de
secuestro en el oeste de Puerto Príncipe
Estaba regresando después del trabajo
cuando unos individuos lo obligaron a
subirse a un vehículo y después lo
llevaron a una celda cuando llegué a la
celda encontré otras 10 personas que
habían sido secuestradas
a partir del quinto día me empezaron a
golpear incluso me introdujeron un arma
en la boca las amenazas eran constantes
podía ver la muerte en la cara
en Haití entre enero y septiembre de
2022 se han registrado 755 secuestros en
redes sociales las publicaciones que
señalan casos de personas desaparecidas
son moneda corriente los secuestros
afectan a todas las categorías de la
población y a todos los barrios primero
tuve que pagar una cantidad de dólares
otra cantidad solo en dólares no son
10.000 No son 20.000 no son 50 mil
dólares no va mucho más allá de esas
cantidades
tuvimos que negociar y de X cantidad
pasamos a y cantidad
Patrick estuvo un mes en cauti
verio liberado como muchas otras
víctimas de secuestro no quiso decir el
monto que le dio a su secuestradores
para pagar esos rescates muchos
haitianos deben organizar colectas de
dinero en su entorno
pero el dinero de las bandas también
proviene de empresarios y políticos que
buscan apoyos durante las elecciones
en la red Nacional de defensa de los
Derechos Humanos consideramos que no es
realmente una ideología detrás de ese
vínculo que las bandas armadas tienen
con los y las que están en el poder
pensamos que es un mecenazgo por lo
contrario sabemos que los y las que
dirigen el país utilizan las bandas
armadas para mantenerse en el poder o
para renovar su lugar en el poder
desde finales de agosto en todo el país
se han multiplicado las manifestaciones
para denunciar la inseguridad el costo
de la vida y exigir la renuncia del
Primer Ministro Ariel
quiero rendirle homenaje al pueblo
haitiano por su resistencias su valentía
su determinación en la lucha que lleva a
cabo para cambiar sus condiciones de
vida
en medio de este caos algunos jefes de
las bandas como barbecue en este vídeo
tratan de hacerse pasar por líderes
políticos a pesar de sus abusos
la oficina del Primer Ministro y la
policía haitiana no respondieron a
nuestra solicitudes de entrevista a
principios de octubre el Primer Ministro
hizo un llamado para que se desplegara
una Fuerza Armada internacional una
petición rechazada por gran parte de la
sociedad haitiana que quiere ante todo
un cambio de gobierno con la ínfima
esperanza de sacar al país de este
vórtice infernal